وزير خارجيه اوكرانيا يحث المانيا على
ارسال المزيد من الذخيره وتدريب الطيارين
البرهان
تشكيل اللجنه عسكريه لمتابعه الوضع في اول
اجتماع منذ الخلاف الاخير
[موسيقى]
حياكم الله مشاهدينا الكرام اهلا بكم معنا
الى هذه النشره المفصله تاتيكم من العربيه
حتى وزير الخارجيه الاوكرانيه
ديميتروكوليبا المانيا على الاسراع في
تقديم امدادات الذخيره والبدء في تدريب
الطيارين الاوكرانيين على طائره مقاتله
غربيه وقال كوليبا لصحيفه بلد الالمانيه
ان نقصد خيره يعد المشكله الاولى التي
تواجه اوكرانيا لصد الغزو الروسي مضيفا ان
الشركات الالمانيه المصنعه للاسلحه ابلغته
خلال مؤتمر ميونخ للامن الشهر الماضي انها
جاهزه لعمليه تسليم لكنها تنتظر توقيع
الحكومه على العقود
ميدانيا قال تقرير صادر عن وزاره دفاع
البريطانيه ان قوات فاجنر الروسيه باتت
تسيطر على الجانب الشرقي من مدينه باخمت
لكن عبور النهر الذي يقسم المدينه في
المنتصف اصبح يشكل خط المواجهه بين
الجانبين وان عبوره يعتبر تحديا امام
القوه المهاجمه في المقابل قال قائد لواء
الدبابات والجيش الاوكراني ليونيت ان
الدبابات الغربيه ستغير من تكتيكات الحرب
بشكل كبير وذلك لما تمتلكه الدبابات
الغربيه من قدرات عاليه
سيتغير مفهومه وتكتيكات استخدام الدبابات
في المعركه بشكل كبير لان الدبابات
الغربيه لديها مدى رمايه الاعلى وقدرات
اخرى مثل مجال المعلومات الرقميه وذلك اذا
تم استخدام هذه الدبابات بالشكل الصحيح
كما تمكننا من تدمير العدو قبل الاقتراب
من نطاق المعركه
قال المتحدث باسم القوات الاوكرانيه في
شرق البلاد ان اكثر من 500 جندي روسي لقوا
حتفهم او اصيبوا خلال 24 ساعه في المعارك
الدائره في مدينه بخمت من جانبها قالت
وزاره الدفاع الروسيه انما يصل الى 210
جنود اوكرانيين قتلوا في الجزء الذي يمثل
خط المواجهه الاوسع نطاقا في دوناتسك ولم
تحدد موسكو حجم الخسائر في باخماط لكن
المدينه الواقعه في شرق دوناسك ويصعب
التحقق من العدد الدقيق للقتله من مصادر
مستقله
على ضفتين الرباخ موت تستعير المعارك بين
المقاومين الاوكران وقوات فاكنال الروسيه
لكن التقدم متوقف وبحاجه لمغامره من
المهاجمين قد تكون نتائجها وخيمه النهر
الذي يقطع المدينه من المنتصف تحول الى خط
مواجهه شرقه تتمركز قوات فاجدا بينما
يتمترس الاوكرانيون غربه وما بينهما حولته
كثافه النيران الى ساحه للقتل والموت وفقا
لتقرير صادر عن وزاره الدفاع البريطانيه
فان المحاولات الروسيه مستمره لتطويق
المقاومين الاوكرانيين حيث يحاولوا
المهاجمون تطويق المدينه من ثلاث جهات لكن
تكتيك كييف في تدمير الجسور والطرق شكل
تحديا كبيرا امام المهاجمين اضافه لنيران
القناصه الاوكرانيين من جهه الغرب
التي تقود الهجوم على باخموت ومع التقدم
الضئيل في الميدان تشتكي من قله الذخيره
والتسليح امر يضيف تحديا جديدا في وجهها
هذا مبنى اداره المدينه هذا هو وسط
المدينه على بعد مسافه كيلو متر و200 متر
اهم شيء الان هو الحصول على الذخيره
والمضي قدما في معركه باكموت المستمره منذ
قرابه ثمانيه شهور بدا حساب الفارق بين
النصر والهزيمه بالامتار لكنها امتار بنهر
من النار والجحيم رائد المصطفى العربيه
في ظل التزايد التوتر بين قائد مجموعه
فاغنريفجيني بريكوجين والكرملين كشفت
تقارير اعلاميه امريكيه عن وجود رغبه لدى
بعض المسؤولين الروسي كبح جماح بريكوجين
خاصه بعد تاخره في انجاز المهمه المنوطه
به بالسيطره على باخمات
المقاتلون يسالونني لماذا التاخير في
امدادات الذخيره التي تعهدت بها وزاره
الدفاع الروسيه يجب شرح ذلك في موسكو
وايضا لماذا لا يسمحون لنا بتجنيد عناصر
الجدد
هو مجرد تصريح من بين تصريحات اخرى لقائد
مجموعه فاجنر
الذي رفع رايه التمرد في وجه الكريم
بدات كما لو انها فقدت السيطره عليه وباتت
ترغب الان في كبح جماحها صحيفه وولد اكدت
نقلا عن مسؤول امريكي ان بريكوجين تحول
الى رجل قوي قادر على الوقوف ضد اعضاء
الحكومه الروسيه ووزاره الدفاع الروسيه
والمؤسسه الامنيه الرسميه وبحسب الصحيفه
فان مؤسس فاجنر بدا يفقد ثقه موسكو بعد
تصعد غضب النخبه السياسيه والعسكريه
الروسيه من تصريحاته وتصرفاته وحسب مصادر
الصحيفه دائما فان مسؤوليه الكريم
وقد قرروا تضييق الخناق على مجموعته وفضلا
عن كل هذا فان كبار المسؤولين الروس
منزعجون من انشغال
بالتصريحات المعتقده بين انه لم يكمل
مهمته بعد في بخموت عدم رضا الكريملين على
بريكوجين دفعه الى توبيخه بطريقه غير
مباشره اذ لم تتم دعوته لحضور خطاب بوتين
في الذكرى السنويه الاولى لانطلاق العمليه
العسكريه كما تم منع ممثليه من دخول مقر
القياده العسكريه الروسيه في اوكرانيا في
المقابل بدا مستعدا للمواجهه مع الكريم
حيث اشتكى علانيه من عدم حصول قوته على
الاسلحه والذخيره وعدم السماح له بتجنيد
عناصر اضافيه لكن السؤال المطروح الان كيف
سيتعامل الرئيس الروسي فلاديمير بوتين مع
هذه المواجهه بين بريكوجين والكريملين
فحسب مصادر صحيفه
مسؤولا استخباراتيا اوروبيا قال ان
بريكوجين سيظل في منصبه طالما ان روسيا
بحاجه اليها او بالاحرى طالما ان المعارك
بحاجه الى مقاتله وسام الذهبي العربيه
اظهر مقطع فيديو عن المعارك الجاريه في
اوكرانيا كيف تمكنت القوه الدفاعيه
الاوكرانيه من القضاء على صواريخ بوك
الروسيه ارض جو في منطقه زابوريا
[موسيقى]
وجه اكثر من 140 ناشطا سياسيا ومدنيا
ايرانيا رساله الى الامين العام للاممين
المتحده طلبه فيها بفتح تحقيق فوريا في
تصميم التلميذات ببلادهم وكانت الداخليه
الايرانيه اعلنت القبض على اكثر من 100
شخص قالت انهم ربما تطورتوا في قضيه تصميم
طلاب المدارس بالبلاد وافاد بيان داخليه
ان من بين المعتقلين اشخاص لديهم دوافع
عدائيه هدفها بث الرعب في نفوس الناس
والطلاب واغلاق المدارس واثاره الشكوك حول
النظام الايراني وان المتهمين اتخذوا
خطوات مثل استخدام مواد كريهه الرائحه
وغير ضاره
من جهتي استنكر رئيس الايراني الاسبق
الاصلاحي محمد خاتمي حوادث تصميم الطالبات
الايرانيات معتبرا انها جرائم فظيعه ولا
تختفر كما استنكر تعامل مسؤولين البلد مع
هذه الحوادث وقال خاتمي انه ينبغي قطع
الايدي الملوثه التي ارتكبت مثل هذه
الاعمال الاجراميه عن قصد او بتحريض من
الغير واقتلاع جذور هذه الحوادث وطمانه
المجتمع بان مثل هذه الحوادث لم يتم
التسامح معها باي شكل من الاشكال
في السودان وفي اول اجتماع لهما بعد تفجر
الخلافات بينهما قرر عبد الفتاح البرهان
رئيس مجلس السياده الانتقالي ونائبه محمد
حمدان وتشكيله لجنه امنيه مشتركه من
القوات النظاميه واجهزه الدوله والحركات
المسلحه لمتابعه الاوضاع الامنيه بالبلاد
واكدت مصادر العربيه ان لقاء جمع رئيس
مجلس السياده ونائبه من جهه والقوى
الموقعه على الاتفاق الايطالي من جهه اخرى
وهو اول لقاء بين هذه الاطراف عقب
التوترات الاخيره وقد بحث الاجتماع تسريع
الاتفاق وازاله العقبات التي تعترض
الاتفاق الايطالي اضافه لبحث التصعيد بين
الجيش والدعم السريع الذي اعقب التصريحات
الاخيره بين قادته
بعد سلسله من التصريحات بين الجيش والدعم
السريع تتراوح بين التحذير والتهديد يا
بيان القوات المسلحه مؤكدا على التزامهم
بالاتفاق الاطري وحرصهم على حكومه مدنيه
وساخرا من المزايدين على مواقف الجيش تؤكد
قواتكم المسلحه وقيادتها
التزامها التام بمجرات العمليه السياسيه
الجاريه
والتقيد الصارم والتام بما تم التوافق
عليه في الاتفاق الايطالي الذي يفضي الى
توحيد المنظومه العسكريه
وقيام حكومه بقياده مدنيه فيما تبقى من
المرحله الانتقاليه
قوات الدعم السريع ترى ان اساس الخلاف بين
من يريدون تسليم السلطه للمدنيين وبين
الذين يتمسكون بعدم ترك الحكم نافيه
خلافها مع القوات المسلحه
الناس اللي قاعدين مكنكشين والناس الدارين
يسلموا السلطه للحكومه مدنيه
في الوقت الذي تتصاعد فيه اجواء التوتر
وسط مخاوف من انزلاق للمواجهه يقلل
الخبراء من هذا الخلاف العسكري الخلاف
العسكري العسكري الذي برز في الساحه
بالايام الماضيه هو خلاف مجمل سياسي وخرج
الى الهواء الطلق من خلال التصريحات ولم
يصل الى القواعد العسكريه سواء كان في
القوات المسلحه او الدعم السريع وفي تقدير
مثل ما بدا صراع سياسي سينتهي صراع سياسي
هذا الصراع السياسي يمكن ان يقرا في طريقه
تنفيذ الاتفاق الايطالي واداره الفتره
الانتقاليه مساله الدمج الجيوشيه واحده من
المقلقات المخاوف بين الرجلين فالحل ينبغي
ان يكون هو الحوار الشفاف واخراج الهواء
الساخن ووضع الحلول التي لا تفضي الى
تازيم التصحيط العسكري وهذا ما لا يتمناه
الجميع خلال الفتره المقبله
الاوضاع في الشوارع تبدو طبيعيه هادئه
فيما تتحدث تقارير عن توتر مكتوم بين
الجيش والدعم السريع ما دفع الكثير من
القوى السياسيه لابداء القلق على البلاد
سالم الهاشمي العربي الخرطوم
قال المبعوث الاممي الى ليبيا انه سيتم
اختيار فريق رفيع المستوى من قبل الليبيين
يتولى العمل على وضع اسس اجراء الانتخابات
العامه هذا العام واضاف بتيلي في مؤتمر
صحفي في طرابلس انه يمكن وضع خريطه واضحه
للانتخابات بحلول منتصف شهر يونيو المقبل
تباينت ردود الفعل حول الخطط التي اعلنها
المبعوث الدولي الى ليبيا عبد الله فاتيلي
والتي ترمي الى اجراء الانتخابات بنهايه
العام الحالي بين مؤيد ومعارض وبين من يضع
شروط للموافقه لانجاح الخطه فاللجنه رفيعه
المستوى التي اعلنت تشكيلها اعترض اكثر من
خمسين حزبا على عدم اشراك الاحزاب
السياسيه فيها والاكتفاء باجسام اخرى كيف
يمكن ان يكون
استبعاد الاجسام الرئيسيه وهي الاحزاب
السياسيه في عمل سياسي مقبل في ليبيا وهي
يجب ان تكون هي الاساس في هذا العمل بينما
ادخل او ذكر او عدد مكونات اخرى في داخل
هذه
اللجنه رفيعه المستوى بما يرى مرشحون
مستقلون ان الخطه رغم ضعف بعض جوانبها
المتعلقه بالجدول الزمني ولكنها فرصه
لتحريك المياه السياسيه الراكده هي فرصه
ذهبيه لك بان هو
اجل الانتخابات او عرقا هذه العجله
الانتخابيه
فاعتقد انها فرصه من ذهب لاعاده محور
الانتخاب من جديد وفتح الترشح والوصول بنا
الى الانتخابات باذن الله من جانبه اعتبر
رئيس حكومه الوحده الوطنيه عبد الحميد
دبيبه ان مطرحه المبعوت الدولي يتوافق مع
رؤيته للحل لما اعترض اعضائهم المجلسي
النواب والدوله على بعض ما جاء في الخطه
اما الشارع الليبي فواجه الخطه المعلنه
بعدم كثيرات واضح اذ يعتبرها عمليه مكرره
ولن تغير بالواقع السياسي القائم
الانتخابات طبعا مطلب كل الليبين ونتمنى
ان تتحققوا نتمنى من هذه المبادره ان ترى
النور في قريب العاشر ان شاء الله بصراحه
الحيوانات
هدفهم الوحيد انه يقعدوا في السلطه وخلاص
اكثر من مليونين مواطن لبي سجلوا اسمائهم
في قوائم الناخ بين قبل عام من الان في
رساله واضحه منهم لرغبتهم في تغيير
الاجسام الموجوده فهل سينجح السنغالي عبد
الله باتيلي في تحقيق طموحهم عبر خطتهم
التي اعلنها منير الاشهب طرابلس العربيه
نشرتنا مستمره وفيها بعد قليل
على واقع احتجاجات صاخبه مجلس شيوخ
الفرنسي صادق على مشروع تعديل قانون
التقاعد المثير للجدل
اهلا بكم من جديد
هكذا بيانوا للخارجيه الايرانيه بان حكومه
الرئيس ابراهيم رئيسي خطط خطوه مهمه فيما
يتعلق بدبلوماسيه الخارجيه للبلاد وذلك
تعليقا على الاتفاق على العوده او على
عوده العلاقات مع المملكه العربيه
السعوديه اشارت الخارجيه الايرانيه لان
الاتفاق سيعود ايجابا وسيسهم بتامين
المصالح المشتركه للشعبين كما اكدت
الخارجيه الايرانيه بان الحكومه اتخذت
قرارا جادا في مسار تامين مصالح الشعب
الايراني وكذلك شعوب المنطقه
قتل الامن الموريتانيه ثلاثه عناصر من
تنظيم القاعده فرينه من سجن نواكشوط
المركزي اثناء القبض عليهم قرب بلديه
المداح شمل العاصمه فيما تم القاء القبض
على رابع وكان اربعه سجناء لتنظيم القاعده
قد فروا من سجن نواكشوط المركزيه لاحد
الماضي بعدما قتلوا جنديين من حرس السجن
وجرحوا اثنين اخرين
احتشد الاسرائيليون في شوارع المدن امس
السبت في مظاهرات خرجت على مستوى اسرائيل
ودخلت الان اسبوعا العاشر للاحتجاج على
خطط الحكومه اليمينيه المتشدده للحد من
سلطات المحكمه العليا والتي يعتبرها من
منتقدها تهديدا لاستقلال القضاء وقد خرج
الالاف في عده مناطق اسرائيل منها تل ابيب
وحيفا وبئر السبع ضد الخطه التي يعتبرونها
ترمي الى تقويض السلطه القضائيه لصالح
السلطه السياسيه وتهدد النظام الديمقراطي
واعلنت الشرطه انها ستغلق عده طرق في تل
ابيب وحيفا ومناطق اخرى بسبب التظاهرات
فيما قدر عدد المتظاهرين باكثر من 200 الف
متظاهر
صدق مجلس شيوخ الفرنسيه على مشروع قانون
تعديل نظام التقاعد المثير للجدل وذلك على
واقع اشتباكات بين الشرطه الفرنسيه
ومحتجين على المشروع
[تصفيق]
[موسيقى]
موجه سابعه من الاحتجاج شهدتها فرنسا ضد
مساء الحكومه رفع سن التقاعد الى 64 عاما
ترافقت الاحتجاجات مع اضراب شهدته قطاعات
ابرزها الطاقه والنقل حيث تم الغاء 20% من
الرحلات الجويه
ماكرون يقوم بفعل كل شيء ضدنا وفي المقابل
يعيش حياته بكل رفاهيه الهدوء الذي حافظ
عليه المتظاهرون مع انطلاق الموكب الفارسي
سرعان ما تحول الى مواجهات مع الشرطه بضع
مئات من شبان اليسار العنيفين اشتبكوا مع
عناصر الشرطه عند محاولاتهم تحطيم واجهات
مصاريف وشركات يقولون انها تمثل راس ماليه
مسؤوله عن ترد اوضاعهم الاشتباكات اوقعت
بعض الاصابات وسمحت للشرطه باجراء عمليات
اعتقال عنيفه وثقتها كاميرا العربيه
سريعا سيطرت الشرطه على الوضع وعاد الهدوء
الى تظاهره لم تقتصر المشاركه بها على
شريحه الموظفين او كبار السن بل ايضا شهدت
مشاركه شبابيه واسعه
مازلت صغير السن لكن هذا الاحتجاج يخص
الجميع انها فرصه تاريخيه لاثبات ان الشعب
في الشارع ولديه اهتمامات لا تتطابق مع
مدراء الشركات والمسؤولين ولديه النيه في
قلب الطاوله واستعاده السلطه حول العمل في
حصيله هذا اليوم اعلنت النقابات عن مشاركه
300 الف في الموكب الباريسي رقم قالت
الشرطه انه مبالغ به واعلنت انها احصت
48000 في باريس يراهن
الفرنسي وحكومته على عامل الوقت لانهك
الحركه الاحتجاجيه لكن المتظاهرين يبدون
استعدادهم للذهاب بعيدا مهما كلف الامر
فادي الدهوك العربيه باريس
تجمع اكثر من عشره الاف مزارع في مدينه
لهااييل الهولنديه وذلك احتجاجا على خططي
الحكومه للحد من انبعاثات النيتروجين
والتي يزعم المحتجون بانها ستؤدي الى خروج
الكثير من المزارع من الخدمه وتاثيره على
انتاج الغذاء
بعد محاوله فاشله ينتظر ان يقلع مجددا من
ولايه فلوريدا الامريكيه الصاروخ تيران
واحد والذي يعتبر اول صاروخ فضائي مصنع
بتقنيه تراثي ثلاثيه الابعاد والتي او حيث
يتوقع ان يساهم حال نجاح اطلاقه في احداث
ثوره في صناعه اطلاق الصواريخ
صاروخ تيران ثوره في صناعه الصواريخ
صاروخ لاول مره يصنع باتباعه ثلاثيه
الابعاد
سيقلع من كعب كنافيريل بولايه فلوريدا
الامريكيه
تهدف رحله تجربته الاولى الى اثبات قدره
الصاروخ على مقاومه ضغط الاقلاع
الهدف من صناعته جمع اكبر قدر ممكن من
البيانات
تبلغ ارتفاع الصاروخ 33 مترا ونصف المتر
وقطره حوالي مترين
فشلت المحاوله الاولى لاطلاقه الاسبوع
الماضي بسبب مشكله تقنيه
وزير خارجيه اوكرانيا يحث المانيا على
ارسال المزيد من الذخيره وتدريب الطيارين
اكثر من 140 ناشطا ايرانيا يطالبون
في تصميم التلميذه ببلادهم
البرهان واديجلو يقرراني تشكيل لجنه
عسكريه لمتابعه الوضع في اول اجتماع منذ
الخلاف الاخير
دائما لمزيد من المتابعه القاكم بعد دقائق
في نشره اخرى الى اللقاء
[موسيقى]